chuckle hey chuckle how do you implement
change when you know it is needed how do
you implement change when you know what
is needed well when I know I need to
change something what I do is I change
it that's something I change it and I've
had people that listen to the podcast
and they've reached out to me over the
past few years and one of the main
messages that they took and put into
action was actually putting things into
action
whatever that was they they stopped
eating sugar
they stopped sleeping in they they
started waking up early they they quit
playing video games for 10 or 12 or 14
hours a day they sold that Xbox thing
there was a guy that bit his nails for
his whole life and he's in his like 30s
heywhat whatever no big deals right you
know he bit his nails oh you know what
his nails are all chewed up and they're
bloody and they're gross looking at he's
self-conscious when he's meeting people
and shaking hands and he can't keep his
hands away from his mouth while he's in
meetings or in interacting with people
but he couldn't stop and then he stopped
it just stopped and the list goes on
there's people that are quit drinking
and quit doing drugs and quit losing
their temper and I've heard from so many
different people that have implemented
change in their lives so so many letters
and messages and notes and I want you to
know that these people aren't a bunch of
of elite Special Operations warriors
that's not who they are they aren't a
bunch of high-level
athletes or highly screened in highly
trained individuals these are just just
normal people really but they're normal
people that knew they needed to make a
change and they decided they were going
to make a change and then they made it
and that is what I do and that is what
you can do too if you have something to
change if you want to change something
change it change it now